tourne vers vous natacha weis nietzsche
bonjour cyril est en train de nous
témoigner de ces combats de ce déluge de
feu on va le dire ainsi qui s'abat sur
here pin's et le dernier verrou avant la
capitale qui est via une résistance
ukrainienne toujours qui s'effectue avec
notamment des combattants des
combattants et cruelle étrangers qui
sont venus défendre défendre le pays il
y à 7 cette annonce cette offre russe
qui répétait à renouveler depuis ce
matin cette offre de couloirs
humanitaires pour tous les civils
ukrainien qui
souhaiteraient quitter les grandes
villes assiégées par l'armée russe
notamment kiev à ce que l'on entend de
ce que nous dit cyril et cessez le feu
et ses couloirs humanitaires ne tiennent
pas c'est d'ailleurs ce que ce qu'a
annoncé 1 ce matin le gouvernement
ukrainien la vice premier ministre
craignant notamment oui ce cessez le feu
demandé par la russie ne tient
évidemment pas car l'armée russe
continue de de bombarder kiev mais aussi
d'autres villes d'ukraine kiev a refusé
cette proposition faite par la russie de
deux formes et des couloirs humanitaires
et cette instauration de cessez-le-feu
et pour cause parce que on va regarder
sur une carte la russie propose des
couloirs humanitaires pour évacuer les
civils des grandes villes ukrainiennes
mais l'évacuation se ferait vers la
biélorussie kiev vers gomel en
biélorussie mais aussi de soumis vers
belgorod en russie où poltava mais c'est
une ville qui est tenu par les ruses
kharkiv les civils pourraient fuir vers
belgorod également marioupol qui
révèrent
rostov sur le don en russie ou encore la
peau rides jacky est tenu depuis
quelques jours maintenant par les russes
comment kiev peut évidemment accepter
une telle proposition
comment imaginer aussi des civils
ukrainien dont le pays est envahi par la
russie accepte d'aller en russie en
biélorussie qui sert de base arrière à
cette offense offensive russe depuis le
début de cette guerre les mots à pois en
temps de guerre
et la russie par le couloir humanitaire
mais est ce que ce sont vraiment des
couloirs humanitaires que propose la
russie en tout cas c'est une façon ce
serait une façon pour la russie
d'évacuer des villes qu'elles bombardent
sans relâche on l'a vu encore avec notre
envoyé spécial qui se trouvèrent vers
kiev auquel bombardent depuis plusieurs
jours les civils ça serait une façon
finalement pour la russie de deux de
vider ses villes des civils et de
continuer son offensive et sa percée ça
serait beaucoup plus simple pour la
russie qu'il n'y ait plus de ces villes
dans dans ces villes sur le terrain on
parle notamment de cessez-le-feu depuis
plusieurs jours à marioupol vous savez
cette ville du sud de
l'ukraine mario paul est dans une
situation très critique les témoignages
sont sont très claires il manque de tout
d'électricité bien sûr depuis plusieurs
jours il ya plus d'électricité mais
aussi d'eau de nourriture deux cent
mille civils voulait quitter la ville ce
week end avec des propositions de cessez
le feu fait formulées par la russie mais
en fait il n'en est rien les
bombardements ont continué et les civils
n'ont pas pu quitter la ville on voit là
plusieurs échecs effectivement dans ses
précédentes annonce de cessez-le-feu et
de couloirs humanitaires comme comme on
les appelle
ce qui a fait dire à volodimir zelensky
dans sa dernière adresse au peuple
ukrainiens et aux européens que les
russes se jouer de l'ouest se jouer de
l'europe par ses propositions vadimir
poutine qui a dit agir sur le demande
personnelle des manuels macron ce qu'a
démenti l'elysée depuis l'elysée a tout
de suite démenti je vous rappelle le
contexte hier emmanuel macron et bladi
un poutine se sont rués au téléphone
pendant deux heures et l'elysée
évidemment dément
cette affirmation de la d1 poutine g le
communiqué sous les yeux de l'elysée le
président macron a demandé comme il le
fait à chaque fois le respect du droit
international humanitaire la protection
des populations civiles et
l'acheminement de l'aide donc non nous
n'avons pas demandé des couloirs vers la
russie c'est une manière pour poutine ou
délits visés de pousser son art hâtif
c'est lui la graisser les ukrainiens les
agresseurs et c'est vrai elisabeth que
c'est le narratif employé depuis veulent
être bien poutine depuis le début de
cette guerre est là une nouvelle fois
plat dire poutine va dire voilà nous la
russie on offre l'asile à tous ce sont
les ukrainiens qui veulent pas venir
venir en russie vladimir poutine n'en
est pas à son premier mensonge aux
abords elle le chef de la diplomatie
européenne l'a d'ailleurs dit clairement
on ne peut pas faire confiance au
président russe nouvelle démonstration
donc et le pire c'est que de la tenir
poutine va sûrement s'en servir et c'est
pas les opinions occidentales qui le
kill qui lisent mais plutôt l'opinion de
son de son pays les russes voilà qui il
pourra dire voilà j'ai proposé le
cessez-le-feu des couloirs humanitaires
mais kiev a refusé c'est kiev qui est
l'agresseur dans cette affaire et nous
on est les gentils finalement ce sont
les méchants merci beaucoup à natacha
investnews ch pour ce décryptage carte à
l'appui ça bien